good morning john helium is very weird
and i'm tired of people being wrong
about it so i've made a video here that
is everything a normal person needs to
know about helium in four minutes helium
is very special for three different
reasons first it along with its noble
gas siblings on the periodic table are
extremely unreactive for physics reasons
they are just extremely stable atoms
they do not chemically react second
helium is an element with a very small
atom the only one smaller is hydrogen so
it is both physically small and light
some might even say lighter than air and
finally helium doesn't just not react
chemically with other stuff it also just
doesn't interact much with anything
including itself basically it is like
the least sticky atom and when it's
easier for atoms to stick together that
makes it harder for them to be a gas and
easier for them to be a solid so because
helium has so little stickiness you have
to get it very cold for it to become a
liquid and it basically never becomes a
solid of literally everything in the
universe helium is the hardest thing to
freeze so we got a gas that is very
light very small never freezes and is
extremely unreactive and that makes it
useful for way more than just party
balloons you can use it in rocket
engines to push on cryofuels like liquid
oxygen and liquid hydrogen without
having to worry about it reacting or
freezing if you need to get something
very cold you can surround it with
liquid helium which will not freeze even
at absolute zero making it super useful
for superconducting magnets in mris and
other scientific equipment you can put
it in pipes and equipment in spacesuits
to find tiny tiny leaks because the
atoms are so small that they will pass
through even the smallest fractures and
you can surround vital manufacturing
with it to prevent unwanted reactions
with atmospheric gases like oxygen when
making semiconductors or doing high
quality welding no one piece of the
helium use pie is the biggest piece it's
used in a lot of things because it's a
very useful gas and you might have been
told that we are running out of helium
which is kind of true but also kind of
not a quarter of the known matter in the
universe is helium but that does not
help us because here on earth once it's
in the atmosphere it floats to the top
of the atmosphere and then gets knocked
away by high energy particles from the
sun and we can't get it back the helium
that we use is stuff that was trapped
underground after radioactive elements
decayed into other elements including
helium now often the same formations
that trap the helium also trap natural
gas so basically all of our helium is a
byproduct of pulling natural gas out of
the ground to burn it in our stoves and
to heat our houses in fact the majority
of the helium that is put out of the
ground in natural gas ends up being
vented we don't even capture it because
it's very energy intensive to do that
and this was extra not done for a very
weird reason which is that the us had a
gigantic strategic reserve of helium
that eventually was like actually we
don't need this and so congress told the
helium reserve you have to sell all of
your helium by a certain date we don't
care what price you sell it at which
absolutely tank the price of helium thus
natural gas producers had no incentive
to invest in the equipment that refines
helium from natural gas but as that
supply has been sold off which i think
as of now is done with and as
applications for helium have increased
more of it is being captured the bad
news is the long-term goal is to leave
the natural gas in the ground because it
and the products of its combustion are
making the earth warmer so now for like
the first time ever we have people
specifically drilling for helium which
doesn't necessarily have to come along
with natural gas that has resulted in
the discovery of a helium reserve in
tanzania which is big enough to fill 1.5
million mri machines and more helium
resources have been found in canada and
australia as of now because of pandemic
induced consumption decreases and new
production coming online the helium
shortage appears to be over with the
discovery of new reserves and also a lot
of the uses of helium including mris and
rocket launches and manufacturing
finding ways to capture and reuse the
helium because of course it doesn't get
used up it's an element that doesn't
react with anything i might have good
news we can all probably be a little
less concerned about at least this one
thing john i'll see you on tuesday
hank why didn't you talk about the
awesome socks club at all
because it's been going very well and i
think that regardless of what i say
right now it's gonna sell out in the
next two days we will stop selling
sunday at midnight but also according to
my projections we're not to make it that
far so if you want to sign up there's a
link in the description